If you're a landscape or a pool builder, go grab some popcorn because I'm about to
show you exactly how one of my clients made 182,000 in just 30 days.
This client does not have a crazy online presence as you guys can see.
We have five followers on Facebook, 160 on Instagram, yet he's still sitting at home
just chilling stacked up.
You might be wondering, Cesar, how did you do it?
We created a meta campaign to generate some leads that generated almost 70 leads in just
the first 32 days, $24 cost per lead and spending a total of 1,675 to get these results.
The reason why we're able to perform so good is because we actually do everything for you.
We do the filming for you ads, we do the scripting, we do the editing, we do everything.
We send our camera crew, we take our drones, professional cameras, you name it.
That's what we're able to perform.
We're not a cookie cutter company that is taking stock pictures, stock footage to make your
ads.
If you want to prove, here it is.
You guys can see our client, Jerry, send clothes on for $14K, $22K, $13K, $60K, $13K,
and I sent a text just to confirm Jerry, we closed $182,000 in the first month.
He said, yes, it was so good that he even referred me to his buddies.
He has a contractor friend that he said, yo Cesar, I have a friend, he's ready to go.
Pretty much already sold him on your service.
We're a contractor and you want me to do the exact same thing for your business.
Just comment the word ads and we'll be in touch with you.